hello there it's update day once again
in the world of fortnite and this week
we'll go down in history as a special
one i'm adam maru and these are all the
map updates and secret story beats in
fortnite chapter three season three week
three let's go
have you visited logjam recently last
week the roots of the reality tree
emerged from the ground in the water and
then a sapling sprouted up this week
that sapling is a full-sized tree and
the poi is now log jam lotus
here's the most spectacular thing about
this place it changes before each match
you play the first time i came here it
was a gladiatorial city like those in
greece and rome from the statues to this
new style of stone there is it looks
amazing the log jam sign still sits here
in the center with this strange glow of
reality oh and there's a bath house
someone should tell nick a30 to get 100
people here the next time i visited
logjam it was a pirate's bay just like
the chapter 2 poi yet at this point they
are still building the galleon which
once sat here on the water all the
details you'd expect are here from gold
and other plunder to a port cullis the
pirate flag is hoisted high above too so
the third time i visited logjam it was a
wild west scene a saloon was here a
sheriff's office and the bank is being
erected and the sawmill is now a mine
but the thing which i am desperately
hoping is foreshadowing is this a train
track we shouldn't get our hopes up but
if you've played something like apex
legends you'll know how interesting a
constantly moving train is around the
island and you know if epic games made a
train it would be the greatest and
weirdest thing you've ever seen please
epic don't make me beg so three pois in
one this is top draw game design is
there a fourth version which i missed
please let me know this isn't a one-off
change either in-game right now down by
the butter barn the next sapling has
sprouted in seven days this place could
be another rotating reality for us to
explore at this point i'm undecided if
the reality tree is a good thing for us
or the beginnings of our next enemy what
do you say i know a few people will be a
little upset that logjam is gone forever
but it turns out it's actually still
here new and improved in fact the
building being constructed to the north
of this is logjam ready to ship wood to
any place that needs construction on the
island this location is the perfect
place to find the new item the rip saw
launcher hangs from the walls here we
can fire saw blades at each other health
and safety will never know i'm working
on a myth chaser episode about this item
so please let me know if you have any
outrageous myths you want us to bust
another update from midweek was a secret
cave by the reality tree it suddenly
opened as a collective community we did
that we opened that inside were three
npcs from fortnite history bill and ted
the henchman from the ghost and shadow
units back in chapter 2 season 2 and a
trespasser from the days of the invasion
we saw them all fall back down to the
island after the sky fire event remember
what the trespasser did he made a new
home to the north of the island all on
his own and he was quite sad about being
alone well now all three of those guys
are together and the bromance officially
has three members now to this update all
those three lads have gone straight up
left their hole in the wall and gone
walk about they can be found in many
different locations thanks to you guys
on twitter for sharing these they can be
found on mountain tops they could be
found enjoying ice cream or tacos they
can be spotted in cars driving around
they can even be having a pool party and
someone found them in one of the hut
watch buildings very nice but for me in
my game they were dancing at the rave
cave i'll try to get footage of all
these places when i meet up with my
discord later the theory is this fab
three will meet the io trooper currently
all alone and they will become the
fantastic four not not literally the
bromance will hopefully have a fourth
member by the end of the season and
these chaps could go on so many
adventures so please subscribe to stay
up to date with this pointless storyline
speaking of pointless stories we can't
get enough of let's check up on the rock
family last week they were sunbathing
and just vibing as the season title
tells us this time they're still doing
the exact same thing but mama rock is
throwing shade at cipher pk she's
finished reading his playbook and has
tossed it to the side in disrespect
sharon isn't a fan and has already moved
on to another book maybe that's what
she'll do all season read books and
stack them high dad on the other hand
hasn't moved a muscle he's trained the
dog to fetch more slurp juice can mutts
be trained to do this in real life
because i may need one the final member
of the family is continuing his
sandcastle building but it looks like
his ideas have grown and the starts of a
much bigger structure are in place kid
rock may be an architect in the making
he's changed a lot since the days he
used to fall off cliff edges
the slow rebuild of tilted towers
continues this week with a new building
taking shape the clock tower is now back
to its former glory and remember tilted
will be the home of player made
structures and act the same way the
block did i wonder if the chosen
buildings will suddenly appear overnight
or build slowly like this one the
constant evolution of tilted towers has
already begun
so as usual i went to visit the
rebuilding of another hero
truckersaurus and this week take a look
okay there's no change but it is now
possible for a truck to spawn here which
we know is the head of this transformer
but when is the big lad coming back it's
taking forever i'm not too great at
waiting oh hey remember at the event
when pili saved reality bringing a slurp
trailer to the mecca well in the story
we are told it's the one by sleepy
sounds yet in game right now it's back
again it's back in the water i know this
is because the entire continuity of the
story is not watched over with great
detail but it's a shame isn't it that
such a big moment for that character is
kind of undone elsewhere the rebuilding
of the island is almost complete we'll
be sent to destroy the last remains of
io later this week and the places the
missiles dropped are almost fully
repaired the rebuilt road below
sanctuary are now removing the burnt out
vehicles so this should be done next
update oh and a tiny tiny update you may
not know about is this guy lord vader is
here with a couple of stormtroopers too
at the start of each game you'll spot
his dropship choosing one of the many
star wars themed locations to drop it's
then your job to defeat him his blocking
is top draw so try to attack when he
throws his sword or another great time
is when he uses the force to lift an
object your hard work will result in
wielding his saber you could even
pretend to be him and trick other
players kinda like this video i made
that nobody watched self-promotion there
is one last thing this week an easter
egg from day one of the season which i
missed it turns out that at each of the
dj booths at the rave cave there is one
of these a cyborg crustacean has taken
up residency and a few people ask me why
they are half cyborg so here's a quick
recap on that weird story back in
chapter 2 the crustaceans built their
own community and each update saw them
progress through human evolution it was
really impressive to see a pirate-themed
village catching shark fish a viking one
too they even built the pyramids of
egypt before becoming a modern day
society sadly things went a little off
the rails as they made interstellar
testing and finally atomic bomb testing
and long story short they nuked
themselves the last time we saw them the
only way they could survive was through
technological upgrades they became
cyborgs it's been a few years since we
last saw them so that's why they're here
but i'm not sure why they both became
djs everybody wants to be famous these
days so yeah that's a quick recap of the
wobbly blobs so that's week three's
update how did i do did i miss anything
here's some legends who used my code in
the shop and sent me a twitter dm thanks
very much guys appreciate you right i'm
going to make a myth chaser episode and
find out what happens when someone
blocks with a lightsaber against a
ripsaw launcher it's going to be epic
see in a couple of days